- I love when things melt in my mouth.
(upbeat jazzy music)
- We're here today at
Sul & Beans in Koreatown.
- And we're gonna try Korean shaved ice.
- I've never tried
Korean shaved ice before.
I've had the spicier side of Korean food,
but not the sweet side.
- I've never had shaved ice.
I've had a snow cone.
I really don't know what to expect.
- Yeah.
- I don't know what it is.
- I used to have that when I was little
when I lived in Korea.
- We are ready to eat
some damn shaved ice.
(funky rock music)
- This is not at all what I expected.
- Me either.
This is like a delicacy.
- This is condensed milk.
You're supposed to spread it on top of it.
- This is the most magical
thing I've ever seen.
- It looks like snow.
- It reminds me of a cheesecake almost.
- Mmm. It's so good.
(laughing)
- What is this?
- You know that expression,
oh, it's just melting in my mouth.
- This is just really good.
I'm trying to compare it to something.
I don't think I can.
- This is so [Bleep] good.
(funky upbeat music)
- Okay, this is beautiful.
- It reminds me of an Asian temple.
- This is a masterpiece.
I'm scared to [Bleep] it up.
- You know it's a good dessert
when you have to take photos of it.
- This is much more earthy,
so I think red beans
are kind of a delicacy dessert in Asia.
- I just want to eat all the beans.
- I've never had ice that's
this finely shaved before.
- Yeah.
- It's amazing.
- It's very smooth.
- Very healthy tasting, it's interesting.
- It's bomb dot com.
- [Both] Oh.
I really know already that
I'm going to love this.
- It's so crafty.
I feel kinda guilty about ...
- Messing it up.
- I don't wanna touch it,
but I also know when I touch it
it will be the most
magical moment of my life.
- This tastes like an American
version of Korean shaved ice.
- It's so creamy.
- I think there's little bits
of cream cheese in there, too.
- It's not cheesecake.
- The cheesecake is
made with cream cheese.
(laughing)
- Cheesecake bites inside of the ice.
You keep digging and you just
keep on bringing up gold.
- The ice is, it's so fine.
It's like biting into a cold cloud.
- It feels like snow, yeah.
- It's so much softer
than American shaved ice.
- Oh, we have a little toast.
- Trying to make me fat.
- I'm okay with it.
- This looks much like cheese strudel
and I love cheese strudel.
- This is pretty.
It's like something out of Zelda.
- Yes, oh my God.
- I love green tea, it's so good.
- This is just really satisfying.
- This is like the one that you wanna eat
after Korean barbecue
because it wakes your ass up.
- Yeah, it tastes a lot
like the green tea mochis.
- Oh my god, I can't wait.
I'm doing this now.
- Wait, how do you do this?
- Alright, cheers.
- It tastes like a sweet grilled cheese.
- I thought it was gonna
taste more like pizza.
It's sugary, it's like
honey grilled cheese.
- That is so good.
- It's like a sweet
and savory honey toast.
And this rice cake has
a cheesy consistency.
- On the bottom it's slightly toasted,
so it's got a little bit of resistance.
I wanna move in here.
(light music)
- Child, I've never had it before,
but I will have it again.
- A lot of different textures.
- Yeah.
- A lot of different flavors
that really played off well.
And it just looked beautiful.
- This place actually
brought back all my memories.
It was so good.
- I didn't know shaved ice
could be so spectacular.
- Every now and then, you need
a nice cool refreshing treat.
And I feel like this
would be like perfect.
- I really think it's
the perfect date food.
There's enough for everyone.
- Yeah.
- And it's beautiful to look at
and it's very romantic.
- There's this place
nextdoor called SomiSomi.
They sell this traditional
Korean ice cream.
- It's a fishy.
It has good color in it.